it seems like earth had a very long time
like not a very long time without life
and then a very long time with very
primitive life
um maybe i'm discriminating calling
bacteria affirmative life yeah people
would object to you yeah doing that for
sure but it seems like complex organisms
when you start becoming something like
um
i don't know what's a good not animal
like but
more complexity than just like a single
cell
um what what do you think is the magic
there what's the hardest thing if you
were trying to engineer earth and build
a life
and build the simulations obviously
we're living in a video game what this
is so if you're trying to build this
video what's the hardest part without
long-term evolution so bacteria
are mostly single cells they do make
colonies they get together in biofilms
which are really important
but
they're all single bacteria in that and
the key is
making an organism where
cells do different things you know we
have skin cells and eye cells and brain
cells and bacteria never do that and the
reason is probably energy
bacteria don't can't make enough energy
to do that
and so
there was another cell
existing at the time the archaea
and the idea is that a bacteria went
into
an archaea and became the day
mitochondria
the energy factory of the cell and that
now let that cell
develop into more and more complicated
organisms like we have today it was all
about energy so the mitochondria the
energy uh the mitochondria is the magic
thing i think so it's just actually not
my idea it's nick jones have you heard
of nick jones he's an evolutionary
biologist in the uk
and he's he's done experimental work on
this and it's his idea that the defining
point was the ability to make a lot of
energy which a mitochondria can do it's
basically a whole bacteria inside of a
bigger cell and that becomes what we now
call eukaryotes and uh
that they can get more and more
complicated so let me bring you back to
the viruses i want to finish that story
yeah which points the viruses come along
so remember we have these pre-cellular
they're called pre-cellular replicons
right
and um
so we have a pre-cellular stage where we
have these
self-replicating molecules then cells
arise
and then
the self-replicating molecules invade
the cells
why because it's a hospitable
environment and i mean they didn't know
that they just went in and it turned out
it was beneficial for them so it's stuck
and they replicate inside the cell now
where they have pools of everything they
need they get more and more complicated
and then they steal
proteins from the cell to build a
protective shell
and then they can be released as virus
particles they're now protected they can
move from host to hosts
and
because they're at the earliest stages
of cellular evolution they can diversify
to infect anything that arises and that
is why i think
there's so many of them and everything
on the planet is infected because the
ancestor of everything was infected many
years ago so it's easier to steal than
to build from scratch
so it's easier to sort of break into
somebody else's thing and steal their
proteins yes
my colleague dixon de pombiere calls
viruses safe crackers safe crackers so
it's just
uh from an evolutionary perspective it's
yeah it's it's easier to steal because
you can select but then you have to
figure out mechanisms for stealing for
breaking into from crack in the states
well you don't have to figure out it
just happens right
because molecules are so diverse that a
molecule gets into a cell and if there's
a protein that sticks to it it's going
to stick
and that gives an advantage
there's no you know there's no planning
there's no thinking about it right it
just happens
you